uh well if you walk into a McDonald's  dresses Ronald McDonald they let you do  whatever you want  what  we walk in I got to work the drive  through so I would like I'd start at the  one end and take the order at the first  window and then run to the second window  and hand them their food wait wait wait  wait wait wait wait wait wait wait  they didn't know you were coming yeah  but then but wait wait wait wait but but  but corporate setting you there you oh  you just went unpaid just to stir [ __ ]  up and where else are you gonna go as  Ronald McDonald at McDonald's right so  we would go to McDonald's and we'd  always get free lunch right that was a  given you never had to pay to kill time  yeah I also had an assistant too right  so I had a van that had full down stage  at a full-time assistant that set up my  shoes for me and took care of my props  what this was Supply to you as per  McDonald's Corporation so dude you got  an assistant and a van